bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi zinedine zidane s'explique pour
la première fois sur son mauvais geste
en finale de la coupe du monde il
présente les excuses mais dément avoir
perdu ses nerfs pour lui les insultes du
défenseur italien materazzi était
particulièrement graves risques de
guerre au proche orient l'armée
israélienne est entrée au liban une
attaque qui fait suite à l'enlèvement de
deux soldats et à la mort de trois
autres par le hezbollah libanais la
communauté internationale appelle ce
soir à la retenue
en france moins de papier moins de
courrier un projet de loi de
simplification administrative a été
adopté en conseil des ministres il
prévoit notamment la disparition
progressive des bulletins de paie qui
pourront être envoyées par internet
l'hommage de la nation alfred dreyfus
s'entend après jacques chirac entouré de
plusieurs ministres a évoqué la
réhabilitation du capitaine comme une
victoire pour la république
le succès de la balnéothérapie nouvelle
génération le spa se démocratise et
innovent des 20 de raisin au massage au
chocolat on en compte une centaine en
france c'est le dossier de cette édition
enfin français maillot jaune dans le
tour de france cyril de sel 32 ans prend
la tête du général à pau c'est son
compagnon d'échappée l'espagnol mercado
qui remporte cette première étape des
pyrénées cyril de sel sera avec nous
tout à l'heure en direct que s'est il
donc passé dans la tête de zinedine
zidane ce 9 juillet 2006 lors de la
finale de la coupe du monde
trois jours après le fameux coup de tête
qui est devenu entre temps une affaire
internationale
le capitaine des français sort de son
silence il a présenté des excuses et
donner sa version tout à l'heure c'était
face à michel denisot sur canal+
loïc de la mornais
trois jours que la france entière pour
ne pas dire plus attend des explications
trois jours de rumeurs pour une scène de
quelques secondes qui d'un coup de tête
au carton rouge a donné encore plus de
mystère au mythe ce soir chez nos
confrères de canal plus zinédine zidane
parle enfin
s'est il passé quelque chose avant le
match réponse non j'ai jamais eu de
contentieux avec comporte avec materazzi
jamais et là pendant le match avant
avant non plus avant ce qu'on va voir
non plus donc le rien du tout c'est
juste au moment où où c'est qu'il ya
ceux là sans didier le tirage de maillot
donc là il vous accroche wim accroche le
maillot en fait et je lui dis de de
s'arrêter de de me tirer le maillot et
je lui dis si le veux je veux changer la
fin du match donc voilà et là ça c'est
ce que je lui ai je dit il est là et dis
des mots les mots qui sont très dures et
qui le répète plusieurs fois qu'ils sont
qui sont quelquefois plus dur que dès
que des gestes quoi et là vous et à ce
moment là vous revenez à faire échouer
parce qu'en fait je sais ce quelque
chose qui de toute façon se fait très
vite
g
voilà en fait c'est décidément ces mots
comme je vous dis qui me touchent au
plus profond de moi de fait sur ces
images de la télévision brésilienne
le défenseur italien répond à zinedine
zidane revient à la charge et il
continue alors que le français s'éloigne
avant de changer d'avis mais qu'a dit
materazzi
c'est ça serait très noir vous faites de
ces des choses qui voit la fessée comme
tous et des choses très personnelles
donc ça touche à votre wii est un peu
parce que la maman la soeur enfin la
maman la soeur et puis cdc des mots très
durs quoi donc vous l'écoutez une fois
vous essayé de partir c'est ce que je
fais parce que je m'en vais en fait vous
écouter deux fois et puis voilà et puis
la troisième fois vont à moi je suis je
suis un homme je suis un homme avant
tout je vois là je vous dise il ya des
monts quelques fois qu'ils sont plus
durs que des j'aurais préféré à la
limite de me prendre une droite dans la
gueule que quand on ressent et et voilà
j'ai réagi deux fois trois fois la même
chose à dire dont des insultes qui ont
touché votre les femmes de votre famille
quoi votre mère et votre soeur oui
loin de ce qu'on a appelé un pétage de
plombs loin d'une impulsion de chien fou
zidane assume le geste était de sang
froid
mais le regrettent ils
et bien sûr que c'est pas c'est pas un
geste à faire forcément c'est ça ça je
tiens je tiens à le dire haut et fort
surtout pour parce que c'est vrai que ça
a été vu par 2 3 milliards de
téléspectateurs et où des millions et
des millions d'enfants qui ont regardé
ça forcément auprès d'eux je m'en excuse
je le dis haut et fort et parce que
aussi aux personnes aux éducateurs qui
sent qu'ils sont là pour pour éduquer
ses enfants et pour leur montrer les
choses à faire les deux choses à ne pas
faire forcément auprès de jeu je
m'excuse nous excuser auprès d'eux mais
est ce que vous regrettez réellement de
l'avoir fait en tant qu'homme face à un
sommet juste l'ambiance est je ne peux
pas regretter mon geste parce que
regretter mon dieu ça voudrait dire que
que ce qu'il avait raison de dire tout
ça je peux pas je peux pas je peux pas
dire ça je m'excuse auprès de tous les
enfants et de tous les personnes qui ont
vu ce geste parce que c'est des gestes
qui sommes pas qu'ils sont pas
tolérables
mais regretter ce geste ça veut dire
qu'en fait il avait raison de dire ce
qu'il a dit et non il n'a pas besoin de
dire ce qu'il a dit surtout pas donc 6 à
12 ans c'était à refaire vous refaire la
même chose je vous ai assez dit que
j'aime bien ça ce que vous croyez vous
dans une finale de coupe du monde comme
ça alors que je suis à la 10 minutes de
la fin de ma carrière je vais aller
faire un geste comme ça et c'est un
geste qui sera comme ça parce que ça me
fait plaisir de faire ce geste est ce
que vous pensez à ça une minute
non bien sûr vous le faites mais je vais
les serments wii 2 sang froid
je fais simplement de vous avez pété les
plombs non mais parce qu'en fait il ya
une provocation et une provocation très
grave c'est tout maintenant je vous dis
moi g steel et payez payez pas
pardonnable c'est parce que je suis en
train de vous dire là je dis juste qu'il
faut sanctionner le vrai coupable est le
coupable c'est celui qui provoque
finalement l'explication de zinedine
zidane est simple simple comme son
donneur plus qu'une sortie en gloire
plus qu'un dernier match plus même
qu'une coupe du monde
il a des valeurs sur lesquelles il ne
transige pas et puis zinedine zidane est
également revenu sur la manière dont il
a vécu cette coupe du monde et certains
de ces épisodes en particulier nous
l'entendrons à nouveau en fin de journal
d'abord on en vient à ces menaces de
guerre au proche orient où les mêmes
causes produisent les mêmes effets vous
le savez israël mènent depuis plusieurs
jours une offensive à gaza pour tenter
de récupérer l'un de ses soldats
eh bien cette fois c'est au liban que
deux militaires ont été capturés par le
hezbollah
la riposte est immédiate les chars ont
franchi la frontière gilles rabin
tout au long de la frontière entre
israël et le liban l'armée israélienne
est passé à l'offensive
l'offensive terrestre d'abord qui
frappent des villages du sud liban et
des positions du hezbollah chiite
libanais il ne s'agit plus de répliques
ciblé à des actes terroristes mais de la
préparation d'une attaque terrestre
d'ailleurs dès cet après midi l'armée
israélienne a pénétré à l'intérieur du
territoire libanais offensive aérienne
ensuite qui visent des centrales
électriques et des infrastructures
routières trois ponts ont été détruits
ceux des routes qui longent la côte le
but est d'isoler le sud liban du reste
du pays
c'est le début de la réplique d'israël
au hezbollah libanais qui a attaqué une
patrouille tôt ce matin en territoire
israélien
trois soldats ont été tués et deux
autres ont été enlevés et fait
prisonnier pour ehud olmert le premier
ministre israélien c'est un acte de
guerre dont il tient le liban
responsable le liban ajoute in en paiera
le prix en israël règne une véritable
atmosphère de guerre toutes les
télévisions diffusent de l'information
en continu 6000 réservistes ont été
rappelés l'équivalent d'une division
d'infanterie
le chef du hezbollah inferno sera là à
justifier cet enlèvement
c'était un type dit l'unique moyen
d'obtenir par échange la libération
d'une partie des dix-huit palestiniens
détenus en israël dans les camps
palestiniens du liban
des scènes de liesse populaire ont suivi
l'annoncé de la tacc israël qui y voit
la preuve d'une coordination entre l'ès
bola libanais et le hamas palestinien
avec la complicité de la syrie et de
l'iran bonsoir charles enderlin vous
êtes en direct à jerusalem le
gouvernement israélien est réunie en ce
moment pour discuter de la suite des
opérations est ce qu'une décision a été
prise
on ne sait pas encore en tout cas la
réponse sera très probablement durant la
nuit
au liban les ministres examine à l'heure
actuelle les plans opérationnels de
l'armée israélienne il est question
effectivement selon les correspondants
militaires israéliens et ne bombarde et
des centrales électriques des
infrastructures et aussi les objectifs
du réseau là
l'opération pourrait durer plusieurs
jours voire plus si le réseau la riposte
cela dit les islamistes de la région
sont en fait à gaza par exemple des
militants ont distribué des sucres
heures
aux passants en signe de joie il faut
dire que pour le gouvernement israélien
le res bola et leur abbas coordonnent
leurs actions et donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle il doit lancer à l'heure
actuelle une opération de très grande
envergure au liban mais aussi à gaza
renforcé les opérations en cours afin de
rétablir sans pouvoir de dissuasion face
aux islamistes
un gaz un merci charles ou 18
palestiniens ont été tués aujourd'hui
ils ont neuf membres d'une même famille
lors de ces opérations israéliennes en
france attention aux jours aux fortes
chaleurs dans la vallée du rhône
alerte orange maintenue dans la drôme
l'ardèche le vaucluse les bouches du
rhône et le gard
mais la pollution à l'ozone se fait
sentir dans un nombreuses grandes villes
du pays
le gard où le préfet a décidé
d'interdire les feux d'artifice du 14
juillet dans une soixantaine de communes
sur place yannick aroussi christophe la
roque à 38° à valliguières cet
après-midi la seule animation dans le
village se trouve évidemment autour de
la fontaine le 14 juillet en guise
d'animation il ne pourra pas compter sur
le feu d'artifice ici comme dans 64
communes forestières du gard plus aisés
pétards sont interdits jamais la fête il
y avait les gars ont fait la fête pour
un oui pour un non un fait rare qui fuit
depuis sur deux - je pense que c'est pas
un problème
ici l'eau se trouve dans les piscines
mais certainement pas dans les sols
sécheresses extrêmes températures
élevées le risque d' incendies est très
fort une étincelle avec le vent risque
de se perdre dans la garrigue dans les
bois de tout enflammer ce sont des vies
humaines qui sont en jeu aussi bien
celle de la population que celle des
sapeurs pompiers qui interviennent cet
après midi il n'y avait heureusement pas
devant les pompiers ont pu venir à bout
en quelques heures d'un incendie d'une
vingtaine d'hectares en bordure
d'autoroute a eu chaud les nîmois eux
ont une nouvelle fois eu très chaud
le gars est toujours placés en vigilance
orange pour la canicule avec cinq autres
départements du sud est de la france
du coup on s'hydrate ans
c'est clair que non pas sous la manche
très largement dans son droit une
cuvette où un record de température a
été battu cet après midi 38° 4 1 12
juillet ça n'était pas arrivé depuis
un nouveau pas vers la simplification
administrative un projet de loi
contenant 45 mesure a été adoptée
aujourd'hui en conseil des ministres la
disposition qui touche le plus de monde
concerne les fiches de paie elles
pourront désormais être envoyées par
internet
christelle martin véronique danzé vie la
partie pratique
deux armoires pour seulement 15 salariés
pour le patron de cette petite
entreprise de conseil informatique les
fiches de paie lui coûte 10 euros par
employé
c'est de l'argent et du temps tous les
mois il faut il faut signer il faut
remplir à la main et faire les chèques
et les envoyer aux organismes ce qui
représente du temps et beaucoup de
papier puisque est évidemment tout ça
ensuite il faut le placer peut-être la
fin du calvaire des chefs d'entreprise
le bulletin de paie électronique envoyé
par internet aux salariés c'est une des
mesures présentées ce matin par jean
françois copé dans son projet de loi de
simplification administrative
c'est évidemment une révolution majeure
pour vous donner un ordre de grandeur ça
veut dire 200 millions de documents et
que de papier économisées qui pour être
sur internet
à condition bien sûr que tous les
salariés soient volontaires autre mesure
pour les futurs époux ouvrent plus
besoin de certificat médical prénuptiale
les procurations de votes seront
disponibles dans les mairies
enfin on pourra imprimer directement
chez soi ces billets de spectacles
achetés sur internet
en tout 45 mesures qui seront votés à
l'automne prochain objectif cercle de
200 millions d'euros d'économies les
résultats exceptionnels du bac on en
parlait hier et bien le chiffre global
vient d'être publié c'est tout
simplement le meilleur de l'histoire
81,9 % d'admis chiffre supérieur donc à
l'échelle nationale à l'année 1968 où
les correcteurs avait eu la main légère
c'est aussi deux points de mieux que
l'an dernier c'est pour le bac général
vous le voyez que le résultat est le
meilleur avec 86 5 % d'admis et des
pointes à plus de 90% dans les académies
de grenoble rennes ou strasbourg
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
gilles de robien affirmé aujourd'hui
qu'aucune consignes de clémence n'a été
donnée après les évènements du cpe
économie c'est la fin du jackpot pour
les compagnies de téléphonie mobile qui
faisait jusqu'à présent d'énormes marges
sur les appels passés ou reçus à
l'étranger
la commission européenne vient de
présenter les nouvelles règles elles
devraient diviser les facture du
consommateur par deux jean paul
s'appelle gérard griesbeck passer un
coup de fil de la place navone quand on
est en vacances à rome
rien de plus chic mais quand on découvre
la facture au retour ça fait mal un
portable ça coûte déjà cher quand on
utilise un vent sont dans son propre
pays s'ils ont plus à l'étranger se
vient ça coûte une fortune
ça sera pas de sens pour un touriste
français à rome appelé la france
l'italie ou même interroger son
répondeur lui coûte en moyenne 84
centimes d'euro la minute hors forfait
mais le vacancier paye aussi quand il
reçoit un appel sur son mobile
35 centimes d'euro la minute la
communication passe par le réseau
italien mais l'opérateur télécoms sur
facture le coût réel
selon la commission européenne cette
marge bénéficiaire atteint 60 % soit 5
milliards d'euros prélevée abusivement
aux clients par manque de concurrence
nous sommes en train de faire c'est
d'ouvrir marché pour le moment n'est pas
vraiment ouvert
on est en train d'ouvrir à une véritable
concurrence un marché que maintenant et
effectivement protégés le règlement
annoncé par bruxelles devrait diviser
par deux les tarifs d'ici à l'été 2007
les compagnies de télécoms elle affirme
avoir déjà commencé à baisser les prix
spontanément en bref encore nouvelle
amende record pour microsoft la
commission européenne a condamné le
géant américain à payer 280 millions
d'euros pour n'avoir pas correctement
réagi après la précédente condamnation
deux ans le groupe est accusé vous le
savez d'empêcher en quelque sorte les
autres fabricants de logiciels de se
poser en concurrent l'histoire au
service du présent jacques chirac a
rendu un hommage particulier au
capitaine alfred dreyfus s'entend tout
juste après sa réhabilitation est en
présence de ses descendants
la cérémonie s'est déroulé tout à
l'heure à l'école militaire à paris le
cac dreyfus est devenu un symbole de
l'erreur judiciaire et de l'intolérance
daniel wolfromm virginie travers le chef
de l'état dans la cour d'honneur de
l'école militaire à paris
tout un symbole c'est ici qu'en 1895 le
capitaine dreyfus subi la pire
humiliation pour un soldat la
dégradation pour crime de haute trahison
une des rares photos de l'époque
montrent la scène des milliers de
badauds suspendus aux grilles hurlent
leur haine des juifs
l' affaire dreyfus va durer 12 ans
diviser la france en deux camps
irréductible et menacé la république
mais il ya un siècle le capitaine été
réhabilité élevé au grade de commandant
et recevait la légion d'honneur le 20
juillet 1906 dans cette même cour de
l'école militaire réhabilitation de
dreyfus
c'est la victoire de la république
c'est la victoire de l'unp idée de la
france le refus du racisme et de
l'antisémitisme
la défense des droits de l'homme la
primauté de la justice toutes ces
valeurs font aujourd'hui partie de notre
héritage
mais pour certains spécialistes de la
faire une institution n'a pas encore
pleinement admis le capitaine dreyfus
parmi les siens l'armée je pense ne
revendique pas encore dreyfus comme un
officier un officier représentatif des
valeurs militaires et peut-être le
dernier enjeu du combat pour la vérité
historique est bien c'est de faire
prendre conscience aux officiers qu'ils
ont là un officier exemplaire
aujourd'hui en france une douzaine de
villes
rendent hommage à alfred dreyfus aux
convictions républicaines de l'officier
et au courage de l'homme à l'étranger
les suites de l'attentât de bombay en
inde dernier bilan au moins 200 tué 700
blessés les attaques les plus sanglantes
depuis des années en inde n'ont toujours
pas été revendiqué mais les soupçons se
portent sur les groupes islamistes
yasmina farber mohan tu salis est l'une
des 200 victimes des attentats de bombay
il avait 47 ans rentrait du bureau un
peu plus tôt que prévu par le train de
banlieue qui a explosé et must nous
resterons unis remonte les auteurs de
cet attentat n'ont pas compris que nous
ne la laisserons jamais gagné oui les
enquêteurs continuent les investigations
les terroristes ne viser que des
voitures première classe comme un
message spécial adressé à la capitale
financière
un symbole de mondialisation un minuteur
a été retrouvé selon la police une
puissance importante est derrière cette
opération bien préparé
l'explosif utilisé est introuvable en
inde ce sont donc des éléments
extérieurs qu'ils ont fourni à des gens
d'ici selon la presse indienne
l'attentât porte la signature du lashkar
e taïba un groupe extrémiste islamiste
basé au pakistan
des militants qui revendique la
souveraineté sur le cachemire indien est
le leader de ce groupe a formellement
démenti ce massacre furent selon les
experts en terrorisme
l'attak du train de bombay porte d'abord
la marque d'al qaïda
pour le groupe d'oussama ben laden
l'inde est une terre de jihad
avec ses 120 millions de musulmans au
milieu de 800 millions d'hindous tout le
pays
vite aujourd'hui en état d' alerte la
crise nucléaire iranienne les six
grandes puissances france allemagne
chine etats unis royaume uni et russie
ainsi que le représentant l'union
européenne étaient réunis aujourd'hui à
paris pour à trouver une position
commune
les espoirs de négociation mais il y a
deux mois ont fait long feu
les grandes puissances ont donc décidé
de hausser le ton face à téhéran en
renvoyant le dossier à nouveau devant le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu en vue
d'éventuelles sanctions
les préparatifs des cérémonies du 14
juillet
et parmi les hommes qui vont défiler
certains militaires engagés dans des
missions à risque en afghanistan par
exemple plus d'un millier de français
sont actuellement là bas l'une de nos
équipes a vu passer plusieurs jours avec
eux poursuivre leur mission au nord de
kaboul
envoyés spéciaux bertrand coq gilles
jacquier départ en patrouille pour ses
hussards parachutistes en afghanistan
depuis février sur la route de bagram
dans la plaine de chamali les français
sont en terrain connu quatre ans qu'il
nomma 10 ce secteur du nord de kaboul
connu mais pas pour autant familier
barrières culturelles vraiment très
important notre
notre civilisation occidentale et puis
ce pays
mais je pense que c'est par par des
contacts proches dans des contacts
réguliers
on appréhende un petit peu mieux la
situation est entre les gars qu'on
serait accepté loin des routes
d'infiltration des talibans le secteur
est relativement calme des villages
isolés de paysans éleveurs dont les
malek les barbes blanches n'hésite pas à
s'adresser aux français quand ils ont
besoin de quelque chose
cela voudrait une clinique au fil des
mois se sont noués des rapports de
confiance on va pas se cacher dans les
coins pourra décider vraiment du monde
partout la construction se met à l'aise
pour les mettre à l'aise et a créé pour
un dialogue facilement un dialogue
intéressés dont le but est d'obtenir des
renseignements et dont personne n'est
dupe
je préfère voir les français chez nous
ici le parc le jour même où recommencera
à se battre et à s'entretuer quatre ans
et demi après le départ des talibans à
kaboul la capitale a doublé sa
population
fin mai un accident de la circulation
provoqués par les américains avaient
dégénéré en émeutes
pendant quinze jours les français ont
suspendu leurs patrouilles à pied puis
les lieutenants ont repris le contact
avec les maires de district ici aussi
c'est donnant donnant le fonctionnaire
se plein de promesses non tenues
ils ont promis mercredi inclus dans le
pack la veille ils ont pas tenu leurs
promesses encore on espère qu'il le
tient leurs preuves et celles qui fixent
le problème non par une autre voie et
que l'on n'a pas l'habitude de mentir
non
mais promis qu'on allait faire depuis on
s'engage à faire des jeux bobigny
sociale le français soutiendra quand
même quelques informations sur l'état
d'esprit de la population toute manière
les renseignements intéressants nous
arrive souvent au détour d'une
conversation
ce n'est pas en les forçant que
chroniqueur second set était l'otan
prend le contrôle de l'afghanistan les
français conservent kaboul
une présence qui pourrait se révéler
piégeuse temps la situation se dégrade
dans tout le pays images de l'espace
avec la troisième sortie depuis le début
de la mission de deux astronautes de
discovery ont testé des techniques de
réparation aujourd'hui pendant plus de
six heures la navette américaine amarrée
à la station spatiale internationale
doit revenir sur terre
lundi prochain et à propos d' espace
l'europe s'apprête à lancer le satellite
météo le plus précis du monde pour
améliorer les prévisions et si possible
prévoir les intempéries si explications
nicolas chateauneuf philippe lutz y lire
dans les nuages le temps qu'il fera
demain un vieux rêve que l'homme a peu à
peu rendu possible en étudiant
l'atmosphère et le climat grâce à des
instruments toujours plus sophistiqués
le dernier en date le voici mais tom
lancé de baïkonour le satellite européen
doit tout simplement révolutionné la
prévision météo et l'étude du climat
premier atout contrairement aux autres
satellites météo rhdp 1 qui stationnent
à trente six mille kilomètres au dessus
de l'europe
metop lui tournera autour de la terre à
820 km du sol seulement plus près metop
sera donc beaucoup plus précis le
satellite pourra également mesuré de
nombreux paramètres de l'atmosphère avec
une précision inégalée
la température de l'air le taux
d'humidité ou même la vitesse du vent au
dessus des océans des données très
utiles pour les prévisions météo à long
et moyen terme
il a très attendu non pas uniquement par
les européens mais également par les
services de météorologie et de
climatologie aux etats-unis également qu
est-ce qu il n'y a pas l'équivalent sur
les satellites américains
metop à d'autres talents notamment celui
de pouvoir analyser dans l'atmosphère
les fameux gaz à effet de serre qui joue
un rôle dans le réchauffement climatique
d'autres gaz sont également suivis comme
ceux issus de la pollution ou l'ozone
des informations très attendu cette fois
parce qu'ils cherchent à comprendre les
mécanismes et l'évolution du climat
terrestre
metop est le premier d'une série de
trois satellites le programme entier
coûtera 2 milliards quatre cent mille
euros
les vacances avec le nouveau visage de
la balnéothérapie laisse pas autrefois
réservé aux plus fortunés se démocratise
on en compte maintenant une centaine en
france et la fantaisie est au programme
ben de raisin ou massage au chocolat
c'est le dossier de cette édition il est
signé stèle colin mathieu dreujou
hippocrate en parlait déjà fait vieillir
si les bains revigorant ne date pas
d'hier
en revanche ce qui est nouveau c'est
leur multiplication
une bonne centaine aujourd'hui en france
contre une poignée il ya quatre ans
seulement
on peut passer deux heures à se faire du
bien sans pour autant s'entraîner dans
une mise en scène trop compliqué enfin
tout est assez simple en vérité ce genre
de temps que le satisfait aujourd'hui
une quête de bonheur voire de
spiritualité alors moi je pense que une
journée de hammam vaut une semaine de
vacances déjà donc avons un film moins
très infime il ya cette sensation de
purification doux l'avènement d'un
nouveau concept le séjour spa au coeur
des vignes du bordelais une équipe de
chercheurs est un jeune entrepreneur ont
inventé la vinothérapie c'était en 93
ils sont arrêtés devant la grosse benne
remplie de pépin dont on se débarrasse à
la fin des vendanges et m'ont dit que
c'était la partie la plus intéressante
de la vigne puis ce qu'elle contenait
des polyphénols qui sont les plus
puissants antioxydants produit par la
nature ces antioxydants vous vendent la
promesse d'une éternelle jeunesse
ici le luxe se satisfait d'un gommage
aux que tu as besoin d'un bain dans une
barrique et 2 beaucoup d'attention le
client reviendra c'est sûr mais à une
condition qu'ils aient le sentiment que
l'on s'occupe de lui
rien que de lui monsieur ont embarqué
par madame succombe lui aussi au début
j'ai cru que c'était un petit peu
réticents on se dit c'est toujours
réservé aux femmes voient une certaine
que les personnes mais après on nous
faut qu'on y passe et je pense que
change d'avis en latin sanitas paiera
quoi la santé par les eaux trois petites
lettres qui ont le pouvoir de changer
l'eau en sommes on part d'un ordre d'un
marché très luxe très haut de gamme
réservé l'élite et petit à petit ça
descend et ça se dit fusion va arriver à
n'est ce pas low cost prix soldés prix
réduit en attendant
pas un palace sens pas devenu presque
obligatoire pour retenir la clientèle
et comme on n'attrape pas les mouches
avec du vinaigre
ici on pousse la gourmandise jusqu'à
proposer un gommage sans massage au
chocolat
ce concept ex qui titille tous les sens
surtout de l'odeur de l'odorat
travaillons autant dire que les temps
changent
il y à 25 ans il fallait souffrir pour
être belle
aujourd'hui il suffit de respirer
bref à la folie fitness a succédé l'envi
de délicatesse le tour de france les
choses sérieuses ont commencé première
étape de montagne et c'est un français
qui endosse le maillot jaune sert il de
celle 31 ans il est avec nous en direct
bonsoir et bravo je suppose à vous juste
avant de vous entendre
cyril de sel le résumé de l'étape avec
nathanaël de rincquesen et josé
boulesteix voila 2 ans qu'un français
n'avait pas vécu un tel bonheur reçu un
tel honneur
cyril de sel et le nouveau maillot jaune
du tour
dès la descente du podium christophe
moreau son chef de file est là pour
l'accueillir pour partager avec lui ce
moment unique
difficile à expliquer
ne penses que je sais moi que je le
réalise encore il m'arrive aujourd'hui
dans cette première étape de montagne
cyril de sel était intenable échappé
avec une dizaine de coureurs
il prend les choses en main et creuse
l'écart avec le peloton au sommet du
foot et le français passe en tête
seul l'espagnol mercado arrive à le
suivre le peloton et déjà dix minutes
servez ion de charles le maillot jaune
est à la dérive
47' chers pc développé s'est rendu
compte tout de suite aux avances et et
cyril dessel qui a fait mieux placés en
groupe
connaissant sa forme actuelle on se dit
ça peut ça peut donner quelque chose de
bien à la fin accompagné de mercado
décèle poursuit son effort
cette fois c'est sûr le peloton ne
reviendra pas la victoire à pau va se
jouer entre ces deux hommes
en temps normal cyril dessel est
sûrement plus rapide que mercado mais
après 190 km d'effort et l'ascension de
deux cols pyrénéens
c'est l'espagnol qui s'imposent cyril
dessel n'a pas le temps d'être déçus le
voile a emporté dans ce tourbillon
médiatique réservé au leader du tour
et oui vous n'avez pas la victoire mais
le maillot jaune c'est même plus beau
alors vous n'êtes plus un espoir vous
avez 31 ans c'est le plus beau jour de
votre carrière si lille de sel c'est
clair que ça restera un jour inoubliable
je crois que vivre une étape du tour à
l'avant de la course une étape de
montagne c'est déjà quelque chose de
formidable avec le maillot jaune au bout
c c'est incroyable et même ce soir je
pense que j'ai encore du mal à réaliser
c'est un rêve de porter le maillot jaune
pour tout coureur aussi pour scier avant
l'étape c'est c'est sûr que c'est un
rêve pour tout coureur professionnel de
porter le maillot jaune
non j'y pensais pas spécialement ce
matin au départ de l'étape
la stratégie des équipes voulaient que
j'aille dans les échappées supérieure à
18 euros dans un premier temps je me
suis concentré sur
sur les maillots à pois son maillot de
la montagne et puis bon ben je crois
qu'on s'est retrouvés avec maria dos
tous les deux à l'avant de la course et
avec une petite dizaine minutes d'avancé
à 20 kilomètres de l'arrivée que j'ai
réalisé que qui a eu le maillot jaune
qui m'attendait alors celle de sel pour
ceux qui connaissent mal on se dit il
n'ya pas lance armstrong il ya beaucoup
de favoris qui ont été écartés après des
soupçons de dopage pourquoi pas vous
ouais je crois que bon il faut pas non
plus s'enflammer il faut garder les
pieds sur terre
je crois que demain il ya une étape
difficile encore dans les pyrénées
c'était apprennent des pyrénées
aujourd'hui il ya une grosse débauche
d'énergie de ma part pour aller chercher
justement ce maillot jaune est bon bah
on va voir comment j'ai récupéré demain
et on va prendre la course au jour le
jour dans un premier temps et essayer de
bien récupérer ce soir est bon ben c'est
sûr que je vais me battre je me battre
très fort pour essayer de le conserver
le plus longtemps possible mais mais bon
je crois que il faut quand même garder
les pieds sur terre il reste encore des
coureurs très solide sur ce tour de
france est bon bah il va y avoir encore
de belles batailles
merci bas c'est ce qu'on vous souhaite
en tout cas sert il de celle de garder
ce maillot le plus longtemps possible
merci d'avoir été avec nous merci
beaucoup sport toujours en bref la chine
perce aussi dans l'affairisme à liu xia
22 ans a battu hier le record du monde
du 110 m haies 12 secondes 88 c'était à
lausanne le français ladji doucouré est
également l'un des meilleurs du monde a
pris la 7e place de la course
comme promis on revient maintenant sur
les premières déclarations de zinedine
zidane depuis le mondial on a entendu
tout à l'heure ses explications après le
coup de tête qui lui a valu son
expulsion il s'est exprimé aussi sur la
façon dont il a vécu ce mondial ses
relations avec raymond domenech ou avec
les autres joueurs
c'était tout à l'heure sur canal+ il
répondait à michel denisot
je rencontre
on avait quitté un joueur effondré un
zidane triste et tête basse frôlant sont
là regardez cette coupe du monde qui lui
avait échappé on a retrouvé zizou son
regard franc et le discours clair
l'homme préféré des français avait un
message à délivrer c'est simplement de
dire de dire merci merci au football et
merci à tous les gens qui qui ont pu se
tenir
cette équipe de france et qui équivaut
bien sûr par la même occasion soutenu
zidane n'a pas évité les sujets qui
fâchent le début du mondial a raté cette
sortie prématurée contre la corée avec
l'image d'un capitaine qui ignore son
sélectionneur
s'il avait vraiment quelque chose à 10h
à quelqu'un je le vois là je lui aurais
dit à lui et c'est ce que j'ai fait à
plusieurs reprises et c'est ce qu'il a
fait lui avec moi à plusieurs reprises
comme s'ils avaient quelque chose qui
l'avait qu'il avait à dire je pense
qu'il s'agit s'est jamais rien passé
ce regard là quand je sors je suis très
déçu tout simplement je fait 0 0 contre
la suisse ont fait 1-1 contre contre la
corée du sud je sors à la 90e minute
forcément qu'est ce que vous croyez que
je vais faire un grand sourire et que je
vais et que je vais te taper dans la
main de tout le monde non parce que je
suis comme ça
et à chaque match la même question
zidane joue t-il sa dernière partition
il avoue qu'il ya pensé et qu'il avait
même sous son maillot à chaque match un
t-shirt d'adieu où était inscrit le mot
merci mon tee-shirt il était là pour ma
chatte match est là à chaque match il a
été là et quelque part et m'a bien il
m'a bien il m'a bien servi
fin mai quelque part il n'avait pas trop
à chaque fois envie de ceux de se
découvrir et jusqu'à la finale le
t-shirt restera invisible cette finale
maudite avec quand même ce penalty
génial le culot le talent est aussi l'
envie d'entrer dans la légende
je les fais pas ce que je vous dis je ce
soit un tas c'est ce que je dis aux
joueurs après je voulais que je voulais
que ça reste quoi et ça ça reste et je
vois là je les fais j'ai fait ce geste
mon jeu je les fais je pense que même
temps que je vous ai dit de tirer comme
je le tire d'habitude peut-être que
peut-être que je risquais alors raté un
dernier coup de génie un dernier coup de
tête et zidane est parti à la retraite
il l'a confirmé ce soir
et pourtant on pourrait revoir le
célèbre numéro 10 sur un terrain de
football
c'est définitif par contre prendre une
licence amateur
vous avez essayé un quartier de toujours
pourquoi pas
marseille et de tintin il retournait
pour jouer pour jouer avec les avec
l'école avec les potes si les mains avec
le retour d'un autre homme en bleu mais
avec une cape rouge il vole celui là
superman c'est la grosse production
américaine de l'été pascal deschamps
frédéric capron
il y a 20 ans disparaissait du ciel new
yorkais le super
préféré des ados après le terrible
accident de cheval qui devrait clouer
christopher hill sur un fauteuil mais
difficile pour hollywood de laisser
dormir la poule aux oeufs d'or
après les etats-unis la france découvre
donc en grande pompe le nouveau visage
de superman on parlait de nicholas cage
c'est brandon wood un quasi-inconnu qui
endosse le justaucorps bleu moulant et
la 4 nages
vous ne trouvez pas le costume un peu
ridicule mais peut-être que si on avait
gardé celui des années 70 sous 80 jours
actu est un peu comment dire ok les gars
ne vous moquez par exemple quand même
modernise un peu le costume c'est sur le
premier jour quand je débarque le
maillot de l'équipe je me sentais
bizarre mais c'était génial
pour le reste rien n'a changé en sauveur
conscience le de l'humanité super nana
du boulot face à lui l'ex lutteur qui ne
projettent ni plus ni moins que de créer
un nouveau continent en détruisant tous
les autres sur femme géniale mais tu
n'es pas un dieu les dieux sont
extrêmement égoïstes ils passent leur
temps à voler en petite cape rouge et
refuse d'offrir leur pouvoir à
l'humanité je dis finalement soixante
dix ans après sa création superman et
ses superpouvoirs fascine autant chacun
imagine sans peine à quoi ils pourraient
les employés aujourd'hui millions de
gens vous rirez milliards devrait faire
ce qu'ils faisaient dans superman qui a
piqué toutes les armes nucléaires et les
jeter dans soleil obliger tous les chefs
d'état du monde à se réunir dans la même
pièce et résoudre leur différend
parce que superman c'est le plus grand
médiateur du je voudrais croire que nous
n'avons pas besoin de super héros avec
des super pouvoirs
on a besoin de super héros humain avec
une super intelligent c'est un super
coeur et nos hommes politiques devraient
être comme ça
tout cela n'est évidemment que du cinéma
un cinéma spectaculaire outreau n'est
jamais assez mais qui semble chaque fois
atteindre sa cible en fin de ce journal
merci de l'avoir suivi tout de suite la
météo isabelle martinet 20h55 la télé de
sébastien avec patrick sébastien à
demain
autre
à